même s'il s'y attendait le verdict est
douloureux son micro était fermé mais
c'est avec les mains qu'il a communiqué
sa femme nous il ya été visiblement
atterré l'a vu partir pour de bon c'est
dans un camp de travail fédéral quels
excès navale et devra passer deux ans et
huit mois emprisonné il aura profité de
sa dernière tribune publique avant même
d'être condamné pour se déchaîner contre
le président vladimir poutine qui l'a
traité de petit homme reclus de magnac
et d'assassins mais son sort était
scellé à la demande des autorités
la juge a remplacé en cinq ans ferme un
sursis d'un valet avait obtenu il ya des
années quand la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme avait tranché qu'il
avait été faussement accusé par le crème
une parodie de justice
du théâtre à dix neuf années qui
désormais considéré comme un prisonnier
politique de régime sans scrupules pour
quiconque s'y opposent
à l'extérieur du palais de justice toute
personne qui ose s approcher
automatiquement arrêtés des camions
remplis de détenus circulaient dans le
quartier
mais ne vous laissez pas intimider a
prévenu navale mais ils peuvent
renfermer facilement mais ne pourront
pas emprisonner tout le pays
sur les marches du tribunal où il a été
jugé sa femme et son avocate ont promis
d'en appeler mais elles ne se font pas
d'illusions dans les rues de moscou ce
soir la mobilisation qu'il a expiré
scandent liberté mais la répression
continue c'est un point tournant pour la
réussite d'avenir petit niveau je suis
kremlin fait le pari
quand débarrassant de son principal
opposant il va calmer une même terre
l'opposition que navale né à réveiller
l'équipe ii
au contraire de son mouvement paul hus
si camara jirès courage au canada moscou